i think what i'll do is
i will host a viewer tournament i
haven't done one of these in a while
i think i'll take some liberty in
determining the time control
um i'm debating between three and five
minutes
so maybe four minutes is a good
compromise
i'm also debating between zero second
increment
and two second increment so how about
one second increment compromise
we'll do a shameless self-promotion here
400k
celebration tournament
okay i think everything's good
if something's not good i'll i'll learn
from my mistake
dad i'd click something in chat now i
can't see anything
but maybe that's a good thing no i just
broke
oh no something weird happened with
streamlabs
okay let's not flag what should i do
oh man okay i don't need to be looking
at chat
like kind of broke things
something really weird happening with
streamlabs which i'll troubleshoot
between games
okay i'm playing your daddy blake
okay i'm gonna focus here uh
play bishop b5 is actually
let's start with knight f3
we're sticking with more traditional
london
and then yeah so one of the ideas
here rather than being very traditional
um
i go for the more positional play on the
queen side
what happened to my reading we're
playing blitz so this is maybe a
different reading than
while i was playing earlier with rapid
also thank you copy borah patrol
and resilience
i saw something that looked like a
capybara the other day
i went to the zoo i saw one of these it
was like a giant rodent
it looked like a really big capybara
it had a name but i forgot what it was
also triple pawns these pawns are three
times as good
i'm attacking two of them there is one
move that defends two of them
which is this
after which i would have played knight
c3 so here i'll play knight
e5 attacking everything
and then there's a funny line if if
queen d5
i'll play knight c3
losing the g pawn and then i'll castle
yeah oh no my pawn
really where else to go with the queen
okay so after the first 11 moves i
haven't taken a single
or no i did take the knight i did take
the knight
uh is this horse
this is force mate because
the queen no longer defends given the
knights in the way
and now i can take on f7 king here and
then
mate
okay that worked out really nicely
now i have to troubleshoot what i did
with twitch chat
okay next round starting in a couple
seconds
so almost 500 players signed up
playing youth moose i'm in 89th place
but i'm tired for first place because
that's how swiss pairings work
okay let's play i'll play one of these
playing a budapest
or not yeah knight three avoids the
budapest
this is actually one of the things when
you if you do play the budapest as black
you have to be
kind of prepared for another opening
um this is resembling like a reverse
semi-slav
the solid approach is probably to take
and develop naturally
oh
yeah i think white was maybe playing
automatically
um should have clearly like usually when
you put your pawns like this you want to
take back
some way
okay gonna show no mercy here
now the the goal is to win as quickly as
possible
start by checking
it's actually it's really close to mate
i might take the knight
how do i meet here
i'm getting pretty much everything i
could ever dream of in this position
i'm just looking for the quick finish
i guess i need to get a
something to
i don't want to spend too much time i'll
play queen b6 and going for this idea
or maybe takes and then queen b5
a lot of ways to have fun here
yeah knight g4i was also kind of
pondering
but then there there'd be some eventual
knight f3 blocking
he takes another three
okay here i'll take the knight
yeah showing no mercy
can i sack my queen with mates
there's a really funny line queen e3
here etc
i don't see the final knockout blow but
it looks hilarious
i'm gonna do it i can't resist
small children close your eyes
where's the maid b5 oh no my pawn
okay there's a maze
oh
i was kind of playing with my food
i wonder i wonder what the evaluation of
this position is
um the queen sack was so unnecessary
but i didn't see force mate but okay
sawfish just says it's winning for black
it just says to castle and let white
suffer
wow so after b5 i'm objectively worse
or it has one move bishop b2
i don't understand why that's winning
but
um yeah i mean i was trying to deflect
the pawn to
get this knight d5 move in
did you hear magnus opinion on gambits
on boaters live
earlier he says he prefers not to
blunder pieces ah
well you have to treat every blunder as
a gambit
but i guess if he just doesn't blunder
then
[Music]
he doesn't gambit i mean there might be
a different there's a difference between
like botox gambit and staffer gambit
that's that's kind of a funny take
let's play i'll play e4
i'm playing random trap gamer shout out
to arcg3
fellow streamer streams a lot for the
saint louis chess club
i'll play a spanish i don't know
[Music]
so we played once before when i was
white i know we played recently i played
some weird like alekhine recently
i think
but now we uh yeah we're going into some
mainline roy lopez
i'll play d4 here
that's kind of a pet line
so d4 is one way to avoid the marshall
because the main line c3 usually black's
playing this move order
d5 is coming
so d5 here i don't think is any good and
if pawn takes
pawn takes us e5
we actually we could go into a gambit
variation there's a line 98 and c3
i've not looked at this in ages
there's also a cool line like if knight
here there's some variation where you
take on f7
but we're not going into that
as one of these lines which i looked at
a while ago
more for over the board play but i just
haven't played much online
so after c3 i'm pretty much on my own
but there's still kind of like natural
ideas like more space
it's light's a bit restricted
[Music]
have the bishop pair f7 could be a
target
and d6 is very normal thinking bishop d5
here and then eventually e6
just to pin the knight maybe seven that
knight is still kind of pinned
i am temporarily down a pawn
but the hope is to get some comp
actually thinking of leaving the pawn
here
once my queen b3 but then there's knight
a5
i want to leave the tangent because if
takes i want to be able to take back
so i'm considering queenie2 here
i'm trying to create a situation where
it's still a bit difficult for black to
play
because i move like this it just gives
black more room to work with
rook b8 looks very fine so now i decide
probably between e6
or bishop f4
there's also pontics bishop takes
there's also queen e4 man a lot of moves
to choose between
queen e4 actually looks like once you
spot
it you see the the pressure there's not
a5 here
but then takes and i'll still have a
nice kind of central
central bind
knight might redevelop to c5 so we play
this move
discouraging knight c5 trying to prepare
rook t1 thanks for subbing
zj3
i'm posting more eric rosenclips on
youtube um
yeah daily clips are added to the
channel or one clip a day basically
so um yeah jonathan trots is actually
doing almost all the editing for the
channel
so shout out to jonathan but uh yeah we
have a steady stream of clips
being released
96 is coming
so i'm still down the pawn um but i have
uh yeah i have this idea threatening a
triple fork
the thing about a triple fork you can
only move one of these pieces at a time
and black can also counter attack
yeah i'm definitely more comfortable
here play queen f3
still looming
and yeah the problem here is now the
bishop's not defended i'm still hitting
the rook
so winning the exchange
i'm not sure i'm not sure if there was a
better defenser for black
the question is do i want to take the
rook or do i want to keep my
majestic knight i kind of want to play
this move
just creating more threats
i'm making a an additional threat here
which
um which makes it so black
really doesn't have time to save the
rook yeah because i was threatening 97
to fork the king and queen
now i probably take
even though i don't really want to
let's take
i'm just trying to keep the pressure
ooh i'm sensing some other meat but it
takes a long time for the night to get
there
if we trade in this move first
there's eventual prospect of doing some
some things on each seven
there's all these meeting ideas like
back rank mate
h-file mate
oh wow the answer is fries thanks for
gifting subs
i was wondering what was triggering the
sub sound
okay i want to stay focused so
i'm still not seeing easy easy win
play queen f5 also may i say crushing
the birds twice with queen side castling
is content of deluxe yeah
class that doesn't happen too often
thanks for that calling roddy
okay now probably take some takes and
will enjoy life
i do have to watch out for my back rank
oh there's a cool finish so takes takes
rook g7
uh i guess i was hallucinating
i guess rook g7 in that line is met with
rick d8
pinning the queen so there's no back
ring mate
and this is mate okay okay that was uh
that was a feel good game
a nice sort of spanish type gambit
make sure the tournament's open
[Music]
this is a playable line for black but
pretty sure black needs to be like well
prepared because it's easy to get into
trouble
as we saw in the game um and maybe
yeah maybe this isn't the best approach
engine's giving a
nice plus for whites
yeah the the most common move
on the chassis and i think in the
masters database too is just to play d6
and this transposes into usually
transposes into this line
where there's bishop g4 and then there's
some theory
oh two games left oh this is actually an
interesting
games only feature kings and oh black
plunger oh no
oh no you're a queen
that's hard to win this
but that's that's kind of the nature of
chess you play such a long game it's
easy to blunder in the end
okay still many people with perfect
scores
yellow is still in first place
how many people have three
almost 600 players too i think now might
be the last moment to join
and yeah now like once the round starts
it might be too late
okay playing joyful crown
wait was there stalemate did i miss it
did the game end and steal me and that i
missed it oh no
oh people saying yes i assume people
aren't trolling me wow
i missed it uh
i guess it's a fair result it should
have been a draw earlier
okay opponent seems prepared so i had
this line earlier this stream
it was like non-stafford petrov
variation
comment from truebear us saying you
should upload five to seven clips daily
even if they're just 10 to 20 seconds in
length
yeah the thing is i don't want to
overwhelm people with too much content
i guess if you want to like binge watch
you can always go back and watch
the older clips also posting trying to
post daily on the main channel too
which are much longer videos so i don't
want to be like competing with myself
and is the greatest chess competitor
ever in the history of chess but how
could they play so many famous players
and not have a rating
oh n n it took me a moment to
understand what that was referring to
uh what does n stand for
not known no that would be nk
no oh no name maybe it's also the
initials of my high school
niles north shout out to niles north
neural network oh neural network is also
a very strong chess player
if we're referring to like leela or
alpha zero
this should be good for white or it
should be good for black
i'm not seeing i'll play this move
trying to be a little bit tricky here
okay so i played queen e7 with intention
of winning
a pawn this might be overly greedy but
a pawn is upon
i might not be winning a pawn if i take
the pawn there's rook be one and then i
end up losing a pawn on e4 but i could
so i could take on
d2
this might be dubious but we're going
into it
might be pulling a yasser going pawn
grabbing
okay i'm up upon
your content is most appreciated
oh your sub is most appreciated thank
you soren kreiger
and karasu morgan cheering 300 says
other day i'd be the 2300
as a 1500 player nice i agree good job
that sounds like maybe one of your
biggest upsets ever
i'm so proud
also okay let's let's try and develop
my only developed piece there was a
queen
uh rook b1 might be coming
wow
so i could take with pawn or bishop
so the point is if i take with bishop
there's rook b1 and i lose b7
if i take with pawn
that might be the better option
and then the queen will retreat the pawn
stays defended
king will hopefully eventually castle
can i do a stafford oh yeah stafford
accepted tournament
yeah i guess i didn't realize i don't
think i've ever actually experimented
with doing a custom
opening tournament we'll have to do it
eventually
interesting move
queen e5
i'm still very much underdeveloped
but if we trade queens then i'll just be
up
i'm currently up two pawns
sometimes the best strategy is to be
greedy win material
trade down and then win in the end game
and so far so good
also thank you t-brace
yeah it'd be nice to do like a thematic
stafford tournament where
you start from the position after this
this this this
so white doesn't have the option of
playing d4 on move three
um so if i take then i can't quite
castle
i think that's okay
play this move
so i'll either castle queen side or i'll
just put the king here
to lead bong cloud and then fight for
that file
i play b6
there's cases where b6 is weakening to
light squares but
i have a lightsword bishop c6 is
defended
i just want to use file to facilitate
trades
e4 is a good move
could push
yeah i think i'll push
it's actually not a bad thing to have
pawns on dark squares like if i
eventually play this
i like being sneaky just connect the
rooks
this doesn't scare me
would be an interesting fiance
also thank you alex 1206
in corbla in the chat what's up corbla
most people who play the bong cloud have
never actually oh
uh that might be true
the other day i raided a freestyle
rapper
harry mack and it was so interesting
because
um the way his streams work is he
he just gets words from twitch chat and
he turns them into freestyle raps
so a lot of people were just spelling
out chess words
and one of the words was bong cloud
[Music]
and he didn't really use it in a chess
wait i have to watch my time i'll have
to find the clip
hey they saying mac you better drop a
song now
i remember back when i was all up in a
barn cloud
i think he used the other meaning rather
than the chest opening
but it was such a cool it was so cool to
watch after the rain
like people brought so much energy he
mentioned my name in a few of the wraps
he mentioned
stalemate and checkmate a lot of chess
terms
okay this is a very comfy position
plan is to start marching pawns
mainly these two pawns
can be patient maybe b5 first
yeah we're both kind of living on the
increments or dying on the increment
okay thanks for the game joyful crown
that's kind of a weird opening
um yeah generally if you play this line
best move is on passant is
uh i think the the clear like best move
here
in london knight or pawn oh it depends
on the position
there's cases where
uh i'll play knight c3
more often in king's indian
setups so if i'm white
oh let's say knight f6 so depending what
they do here
if they play this and i play knight c3
and go for e4
if they do this
then i usually delay c3 because there's
some times where i'll play c4 and knight
c3
um if they play c5 then usually all
if they play like some main line i'll
play c3 here
there's a lot of different move order
nuances which
it's hard to get into now but i did
address
some of the the finer details in a
recent youtube video
my lesson london lesson with andrea
covered things a lot more deeply
can the london transpose into exchange
caro yes
yeah that's one of the very playable
lines for black
it's trendy at some point like very top
level
okay so i guess i'm
four out of four playing leaf in the
wind
let's play let's play a london i'm
getting some london questions maybe i
can
address them
in this game yeah i usually delay c3
until
like much later i like to play the move
order where
um i put the knight here first
okay i just showed this yeah this is
this is like the main line i showed
this is one of the most common positions
in the london
is after castling the main move is
bishop d3 the move i like to play is
bishop b5
in my opinion there's there's a bit more
venom to this move
one of the ideas is actually to take and
play queen a4 and play
against kind of the positional
weaknesses on the queen side
uh which we're going into
so asics kind of assisted me with that
plan
what's the longest period of active play
you went without playing a london
well i didn't start playing the london
until sometime in 2015
[Music]
um so basically from when i learned the
rules of chess
basically basically until 2015
um yeah this is actually one of the
better moves
i'm supposed to take with the c pawn and
then use the c
file
but basically since 2015 i haven't
slowed down too much
but in tournament game i usually choose
based on who my opponent is what opening
i'll play
like i'll look up their games beforehand
and then i'll decide whether to play
e4 or c4 d4 or knight f3
very rare occasions
okay i'm pretty sure this trap still
works bishop d6
there's a common tactical motif in these
lines after queen takes z6 or queen a3
um where now the pawn's pinned it's
attacked twice
if knight here i'll have knight b3 or
rook c1
this is actually one of the reasons why
i play this bishop e5 line is from this
position
it's so easy to walk into the eventual
queen a3 idea
more people walk into it like here
people will play bishop b7 and then walk
into takes takes queen a3
so there's a few different move orders
yeah the loyal viewers will have seen
this probably several times before
it still takes work to win from this
position
because i only went upon sometimes black
will get counter play
i want to take with pawn here keeping
initiative i don't want to give black
time to
prevent me from castling
and yeah this is actually nice because
i'll play b4
like the plan still kind of flows nicely
but okay black is going for some maybe
eventual knight g4
so i could play h3 there's one approach
kind of like h3
because e4 knight g4 is a main attacking
mechanism
now and i'd be happy if e4 now because
knight d4 is just such a nice square
i still have this plan
also doing very well on time because
like the first
i mean most of the game was opening
preparation
[Music]
yeah so the queen probably wants to be
on b2 and then a4
okay five is interesting
i still play queen b2
it's getting weird like structures we
both now have kind of weak pawns
but my knight is in good position can
potentially work with the d4 square
actually i probably want to trade here i
can take here
it takes takes
hitting the bishop and the pawn
life is pretty good here
you always have to be careful like takes
there's rook
e8 i have f4
there's a funny line
so funny line ends up in smothered me
rook here
f4 f6 queen here and then
eventual smothermate
if i didn't have queen d5 then maybe i'd
be in trouble but
i'm also up three pawns okay so rook
there is
logical preventing queen d5 maybe a4
first
chase the bishop somewhere
i want to make it so i can just leave
this as is
and allow f6
not seeing a super clean approach
there's this move
maybe that's the way to go
and just go for the queen trade
if i lose a pawn i'll still be up two
pawns
that's the nice thing about being up
three pawns can lose a pawn and still
have a very healthy advantage
ooh i guess i'll keep
offering a trade
chase the queen into the corner
it's like my queen is one of those um
cockroaches
and this is like a scared human who just
was running
running away now c6
play this move always got to watch out
for the queen because it still has
vision
my queen also has vision okay let's try
and orchestrate this smother mate
just centralizing
casually threatening maiden four one
two three four
ah we're not going to have a smaller
mate
okay so we'll improve a rook
okay i have to watch out for the pawn
i'm just playing extra solidly
one plan is to get the rook to d7 oh
i'll play rook d7 anyway
there we go okay
that was fun thanks for the game leaf in
the wind
yeah got into trouble as black it's
not easy to play after losing the the c
pawn
um yeah i think it's got a little bit
messy
but yeah i was able to
get the nice kind of defensive structure
anyway
okay we're moving on playing karthik
raj kumar
so the yeah competition's getting
tougher
not sure if i want to play budapest oh
we'll have
we'll have a non-budapest i'll be
playing against my own
opening so back-to-back london's we just
had
like a nice london main line kind of
deeper preparation
type trap now we're playing from the
black side
opponent perplexed trying to remember
the london setup
um
okay so with this move order queen b6
has a nice
nice inclusion here and we might
actually go into the game
i showed recently on youtube
hey congrats on being a baby
adfost welcome back
i showed a very um
wait what's the line
i think it's b5 so i'm basically
following the game i
showed about a week ago on youtube
it was a video that was sponsored by
audible and we went into the same
line or the
the grand masters went into the same
line it's important to play h6 before e6
just to preserve the bishop in the event
of knight h4
and yeah so far we're having the same
exact
game oh this is so funny
and this was a key moment as a game
between
nikolov and petkov in that game i think
white played bishop d1
sooner
yes now we're deviating but we're going
to see how black can still
hopefully make progress on the queen sun
i think castling is actually a nice
improvement for white
um actually i didn't show this in the
video either
but one of the ideas if white does kind
of play the delayed bishop d1 and then
takes on a4
which might happen
okay so it happened um then the idea for
black is to
bring the rook to b5 and to
potentially bring the other rook to b6
uh but white wants to play e4 here so
[Music]
have to be a little bit cognizant
of what the opponent wants to do
debating g5 first
there's also king d7
[Music]
actually ricky one's a fine move
okay so e4 is clearly coming
and now i have some choices to make i
might actually play bishop e7 here
that's kind of passive
i could also play maybe i'll start with
bishop h7
we'll see if white actually wants to
play e4
then i'll have a choice between
castling or bishop e7 or even taking
i might have to look at this line deeper
because white is getting the center
simply center play
if we trade
and then king d7
[Music]
it's not ideal
i feel like i had this position before
where i played there's something like
bishop d6 move
and some eventual f6
okay i think i'll go for this so the
point of bishop e7 i'm breaking the
potential pin along the e file
so if takes takes um then
my king's not hanging but well i was
just calculating this takes takes bishop
d6 and then
i think that just leads to a trade i
could start with f6
and then play king d7
there's cases where i don't want to play
king d7 immediately because takes takes
and then knight e5
is a bit annoying
and the plan i wanted to show
is imagine the center kind of becomes
locked down after e5
then there's a cool idea of lifting both
rooks to the b
file which
still maybe could happen
but we'll have to be patient
okay i think i wait a minute
it might be blunders
maybe not
tricky position i'm also spurning a lot
of time
um so the calculations takes takes takes
have to dig with e pawn
and then bishop d6 rook a7 only moved to
defend the bishop
okay let's play king d7 here
oh thank you patrick kerragnar
asking how to join it might be too late
but you can try if you use a join
command
i didn't set any restrictions but with a
swiss tournament you can't join
after a certain number of rounds so i
think it's too late
at this time but we'll do more viewer
tournaments in the future
um can i play this move
there's a comment why i had to take with
epaun yeah and the other line i
was sharing it was a different line but
ippong was not defended
it's starting to be quite late in dk
going to retire from the tournament
gg all along oh thank you to talk to
twaki also
chat donate monies i appreciate that
thanks for being here i appreciate all
the support thanks for playing teotwaki
yeah i think it's common for people to
like join and then
maybe retire at some point also
i'm about to flag let's not flag
play this move i do want to keep one
pair of rooks on the board so i might
play bishop g6 and then rookie eight
yeah as long as i'm controlling e7 it's
hard for light to actually get in
effectively
[Music]
um
yeah we might have to trade f off
everything
which was not my intention
like i want to take with bishop but then
oh okay we're not
okay i gotta move much quicker
97 coming
bishop d3 it's hard to gain time with a
one second increment
it was much easier to flag
we'll do some dancing with the knight
pawns do
at least my f pawn restricts the knight
control e4
walk up with the king
not sure what my plan is here
my plan is just not to flag
use some eventual g6
okay so i'm playing for the win it might
be risky but it's interesting
makes for good content hopefully
hey let's go i'm winning a night there's
no fork because the knight's pinned
okay that was really it was intense now
i'm winning the rook
okay what a game man i took work
good play for my opponents pauline put
up a big fight there
managed to equalize probably too
um three games still going
i have to cool down from that game
probably worth analyzing that game like
after the tournament two
on 400k youtube thanks for the
tournament
oh thank you korean american chess noob
yeah i think we're like across 400k
two or three hours ago um
and now it's at maybe i can show the
exact number
see live count wait
what
oh no what happened to my windows
okay we're gonna play london
[Music]
why does it show less than 400k
maybe youtube's bugging i don't know
i think it says 400k on my channel page
yeah it should say 400k if you're not
subscribed use the youtube command
you can go subscribe okay playing towers
22.
bishop f5
i think i can still take here
i'm actually not familiar with this move
order let's take and see what happens
because most people include knight c6
before bishop f5
okay so now we're transposing to
actually transposing into something that
i showed
andrea botez this knight d4 idea
covered this in the the london lesson
yeah and this leads to just a slightly
more pleasant position for white
have better structure have the two
bishops
still playable for black though
and we might end up actually trading off
the dark side bishops like queen f3
i wonder if it's a caching issue
yeah anyway i was trying to share the
exact number it failed but
uh here's here's the uh actual sub count
to learn not to shake my windows too
much
maybe queen queen a4
there's also queen h6
like that you don't want to take too
much time deciding
i've learned the hard way many times
okay so just trying to hold my ground
like eventually i want to start playing
against this pawn
so if we end up trading the rest of the
minor pieces then it's very easy to play
because i double up on the d file and
[Music]
and maybe i begin the process
let's start with knight b3
have good control over d4
like one of the goals when the opponent
has an isolated queen's pawn
is to control the square right in front
of the pawn which is d4
just so the pawn can advance
i have to watch out for this move but
then i take him
upon let me get to a 1 700 on yeah
nice thanks for the content great to
hear
keep it up karthik menon
i might swing over
let's swing over
pressuring the knight which is not
defended
and still a question of what to do maybe
this move
if takes i'll take with rook and then
prepare the double up
yeah the knight is well positioned on e4
i can block my bishop don't necessarily
want to take too
soon g5
g5 thankfully i have this move
otherwise maybe it would be bad
yeah now the thread is knight f6
oh that's interesting
maybe i'll play bishop e2
because taking probably only helps
plaque
that's interesting like pawns are
controlling a lot of squares
the queen is almost trapped but it's
always going to have at least one square
and yeah we'll pressure the knight
always have to keep in mind like h4
i'm going to be solid though attack the
pawn
put the bishop all the way back so
unleashing the the rook
i'm not sure if i have a threat here
black is defending everything
i might play the bishop on a2
just attack the pawn a third time then
maybe even the fourth time
yeah a lot of maneuvering
it's an interesting kind of positional
build up because now all of our pieces
are
aimed at the pawn on on d5
g4
i mean c4 is a move i always want to be
considering maybe this move
it's getting weird light can go back but
then queen d4
pinning the rook now this is another
weakness like black now has three
potential weak pawns
just put another attacker so i'm kind of
shifting
shifting around like i put everything on
this pawn now a lot of things are
against this pawn
if 94 maybe f3
handsome eric dreaming of you in a suit
okay interesting
um thanks for that
it's sincere f3
again i don't want to be playing too
slowly here
yeah maybe rook four wasn't good we're
just gonna trade and um
it's still pleasant so i still have the
g4 square do have to watch out for the
back rank issues
probably bishop d3 coming hitting b5
also
defending against back rank
now i can win a pawn
okay i think that was the first kind of
mistake
it was all about the pressure build up
well probably this move
i won my pawn
okay now i just gotta be cognizant of
time
control the file probably put the king
closer to the center
the bishop has a square now
yeah that's a move it's actually kind of
an annoying move
knight d2 is some idea
f3 is really ugly but
at least it chases an either way
gives my king some room
tricky end game now
time is not to be admired
ah my pawn at least i'm winning this
pawn maybe opponent is really fighting
this move this might liquidate
yeah i'm just playing for a draw now wow
ah i don't know what happened there i
just kind of got outplayed but
okay still some fight
actually now i'm playing for a win this
is actually really interesting
oh i won on time wow i don't know if i
deserve to win that
that was a good fight though what a game
uh oh next round start yeah there's very
little break next round starts in 15
seconds
man well the game yeah it was tricky
so i was up a pond but my extra pond
didn't really mean so much and the night
was
annoying and the knight hopped in
and like b2 was nice for black
okay well we move on oh i'm playing
speedrun 3000
oh really strong player playing a bird
um
[Music]
okay let's play something
let's attempt to be solid
um what to play here
eg6
i'll play one of these setups yeah
there's really no time to like relax and
cool down
so i'm going for like the early trade
might as well take
g4
g4 is interesting
should not be taking too much time here
i might play
let me play this move
i'm trying to provoke g5 i don't know if
it's what i should be provoking
wait what i'm not wearing shoes but
thank you
my shoes are are sitting not too far
away
i appreciate the compliment thank you
maya svarta on khan
yeah so now the pawn's kind of over
extended i do have the plan
maybe of starting with h6 trying to open
each file in my favor
i eventually want to get this knight to
f5
wow h5 so so quick
i think everything's under control queen
c7
[Music]
it's a little bit shaky could also take
maybe
takes we trade rooks
you start by taking
don't think i mind this
i always have to watch out for f7 being
a weak point
maybe queen c7 to start
a night here in castle
i think the king side for white is a
little bit in shamble so if i can get my
king safe on the queen side
maybe play some eventual move like f6 or
e5 even
my pieces are not too impressive
i might end up gambling or i'm not
gambling gambiting
the f pawn
like queenside castle allow takes and
then either rook f8 or rook h2
also thank you rem remkov rem kovdberg
oh dear either blundered or white's just
playing dubiously
so if i take
i don't see the follow-up
and f5
okay i think white was just playing
dubiously but you never
have to always be careful these
situations rook h2
and start with rook h2
so what does white want to do what do i
want to do
what to do a good timing
a king here
an e4 e4
we trade
from eventual rook f8
that looks okay e4 we trade i win d4
bishop b4 c5
the king is actually pretty safe in the
center
knight g3 avoids the queen trade i have
a5 here
there's also c5
now c5 is interesting
maybe not the most principled move
because i i'm kind of opening up the
pawn structure with my king here but
i mean white's king is also in the
center
i'll take maybe i take and get the
knight here
if e4 i have uh queen h4
kind of a key move
yeah c4 is as thematic
actually c4 is probably a good move
if we trade it takes takes here
there's some risk to that
now what to do
have this move this can get really crazy
takes and then
some night move like knight d4
okay here we can just trade queens
hopeful oh knight g6
[ __ ] d8
i blundered
i didn't calculate this either
it's maybe okay though
or maybe not
what just happened
no no i'm losing
this is so sad
no my my position
wait we drew white was trying to flag me
but we drew because repetition
how did we draw that we drew i was gonna
resign
and cry but we drew
what was that that's that's why you
don't resign children
what was that what's that game i fought
so hard i was gonna lose
i don't know if my point was like maybe
felt bad for
crushing me so badly so gave some
repetition
trying to speedrun me too hard
yeah like this position i can't stop the
pawn the knight is so badly placed
i should have yeah maybe this move
and pawn here i sack and then win these
pawns and
what a game
was that the last round
oh no my tie breaks that was the last
round right
wait one yeah we both have seven and a
half it's a round tournament
is that it i think that's it also thanks
to everyone for playing
fun tournaments kind of impromptu
tournament got over 600 players
um yeah i hope people had fun but i do
appreciate everyone
subbing subbing on youtube and on twitch
and following on twitch
um yeah it seems like
it seems like people enjoy these like
maybe i'll do more more viewer
tournaments more often like the swiss
format
i used to do tapes with the static back
when i was first hearing illnet
yeah you know i cut him open like
surgery rappers see me coming in the
yelling don't hurt me